Like heroes were actually the great
dinosaur hunters of the American museum.
Roy Chapman,
Andrews granger on those guys say going
a certainly a hero.
I have a lot of heroes within my own
disciplines that are probably too
arcane.
But Steven j gold was perhaps my
greatest hero.
I knew it very well.
Uh,
I knew him well enough that I got in
trouble a lot with him.
He started viewed me as this
cantankerous,
younger brother.
He once told a Peter,
you'll never be great,
but you're pretty good now that that's
quite a slap in the face,
right?
We all want to be great.
But it was from Steve Say,
Yo,
I'm great and you're not as great as me.
But,
but I liked the fact that you're doing
good work.
And it was that sort of relationship.
Okay.
But I miss him.
I miss his voice.
He was the greatest single public
speaker I've ever,
ever heard.
He was also the smartest man I've ever
known.
I've known quite a few intelligent
people,
but he was his,
his processing speed was beyond belief.
That's a great,
it's a great voice.
Lost
[inaudible].